Vsauce Kevin here and one of the most
exciting things in pop culture is
murderous in real life it's so deadly
that in a 35-year span police killed
more than three times as many as died in
battle in the American Revolution and
over six times the number of Americans
killed in the entire 20 years of war in
Afghanistan and it's almost entirely
easily preventable it's bad for us but
the data shows it's actually horrible
for cops too and a source on the inside
told me it's even worse than the public
gnomes it's ridiculously simple to stop
we know exactly how to do it and no one
cares
[Applause]
the Grand Theft Auto franchise has sold
nearly 400 million copies worldwide and
some of the best parts of the open world
crime game are the police chases if you
catch a cop's attention not in a good
way and try to get away it's a really
simple concept that hasn't changed in
the 100 plus years since the St Louis
skadoodle cops went on a 25 mile per
hour high speed chase over a speeding
violation One Cop was thrown from his
vehicle and another skidded and hit a
tree the low speeds and the name
skadoodle are old-timey and comical but
this is exactly how it still happens a
USA Today examination of high-speed
chases revealed that about one-third of
Pursuits result in a crash and
culturally we think this is awesome it's
an exciting high-stake spectacle for
those who aren't actually involved the
eighth most successful film franchise of
all time is about car chases we've spent
over six billion dollars watching Fast
and Furious movies Steve McQueen's
bullet and Popeye Doyle and the French
Connection gave us the greatest police
chases in film history 20 years later
the T-1000 is dressed as a cop and
chasing Arnold and the future savior of
the human race through the flood
channels of Los Angeles and in 1994 the
entire world jumped Beyond fiction to
watch by the second as O.J Simpson fled
the LAPD in a white Bronco and every
time there's a car chase today a million
and a half people watch along with
Charlie but the math proves that police
chases should almost never happen and no
one seems to care
here's the data on how police chases
start and how they end a USA Today
analysis of 17 000 police involved
chases showed that 62 percent started as
something we'd categorized as a traffic
offense about half of those being
speeding DUI and reckless driving and
the rest being miscellaneous violations
the chase happens over what's usually
going to be a fine around a fifth were
responses to non-violent felonies like
car theft and burglary and about a tenth
to misdemeanors only eight percent of
car chases were in pursuit of violent
felons and that was mostly robbery and
assault they aren't going 70 in a school
zone to catch serial killers so police
chases generally seem to start for
reasons that are not life or death but
they end with a lot of death Between
1979 and 2013 the National Highway
traffic safety administration reports
that there were 11 506 car chase related
deaths in the United States more than
half of those were suspects
6301 but over five thousand of them were
passengers or completely innocent
bystanders who were just crossing the
wrong Street or the wrong sidewalk at
the wrong time or just happened to be
driving in the vicinity of the chase
those numbers seem bad but remember it's
always worse than you think a 2015
investigation concluded that the number
of car chase fatalities is massively
under counted and it could actually be
over fifteen thousand that's about a 50
increase real quick this video is
sponsored by wondriam the premier place
to watch high-level educational content
like meaning from data statistics made
clear this is exactly how I analyze and
think of the world and it's expertly
taught by Professor Michael starberg and
he has a great quote in his statistics
everywhere lecture that's critical to
understanding what you like about my
videos he says we need to understand the
mathematical and probabilistic logic
behind the statistical techniques if we
do we can be very clear about what the
particular statistical test or
statistical statement means and also
what it does not mean and this is just
one of a constantly evolving catalog of
wondriam content across a wide range of
disciplines that you can enjoy anywhere
TV phone computer tablet or just
download and listen like a podcast so
click the link in the description or go
to ondream.com vsauce2 and get your free
trial right now a free trial of
high-level learning and entertainment
what's better than that nothing I spoke
with an anonymous source who was
involved in examining police chases at
the state level he pointed out that
there's usually no mechanism to report
the police pursue foods that resolve
without incident meaning that we've got
a whole lot more car chases than the
data shows he estimated that over 90
percent of police Pursuits are initiated
by a minor traffic violation data from
California suggests he's right they
found 89 of 63 500 police chases started
over something that wasn't a really big
deal and 90 of those started because a
driver was going too slow too slow
seriously it's always worse than they
tell us let's think about the trade-off
nearly as many innocent people are
injured in car Pursuits as suspects and
the vast majority of those suspects are
about to be ticketed or arrested for a
crime that doesn't present a clear
immediate danger to the community and
does it make any logical sense that the
Authority's response to driving
recklessly is to drive
way way way more recklessly and
dangerously to stop the reckless driver
and it's honestly not just about
endangering fleeing suspects and
innocent bystanders no one realizes how
bad car chases are for the cops
themselves that huge study also revealed
that 139 cops died in chases because
being the pursuer is extremely dangerous
between 2011 and 2020 car crashes many
the result of police chases were one of
the leading causes of death of policemen
ranking only behind shootings and
job-related illnesses making up about 18
of all deaths for cops in the line of
duty but here's the crazy part suspects
are not held responsible for what
happens to the cops if you're harmed and
it's someone else's fault that's a tort
and civil law makes them liable for
damages to you and your life ambulance
Chasers like slip and Jimmy make a
living off of this but cops can't do
anything about it if they're hurt in a
car chase they're generally subject to
What's called the fireman's rule it's a
restriction on the ability of Public
Safety employees to collect damages on
torts in the line of duty even when a
criminal is willingly at fault so like
if a fireman runs into a burning
building to save a child and comes out
looking like Fire Marshal Bill the
arsonist who set the fire can't be held
responsible for damages to their quality
of life it's just part of the job some
states like California and Pennsylvania
have deviated from the fireman's rule
but it's a major consideration if you're
a cop and about to engage in a car
Pursuit you might get catastrophically
injured chasing a busted taillight
there's no recourse and there's no way
out other than hitting the brakes the
British medical journal concluded the
same thing in a 2004 examination
published in bmj's injury prevention
2654 fatal crashes involving
3965 Vehicles resulted in
3146 deaths and 1088 of the Dead weren't
even in the fleeing vehicle a pattern
emerged crashes were high speed usually
at night and on local roads and most
drivers had prior driving related
convictions okay so what so what that
means they're already in the system the
cops know who they are where they live
and what vehicles they drive isn't there
a better way to apprehend them than a
Chase or at least one that doesn't kill
so many innocent people and that's the
solution the solution that's so obvious
and no one seems to care about it's like
the Whopper computer says in war games
every bit of data we have on car chases
suggests that the trade-off we make the
desire to meet out Justice in real time
isn't worth the horrible consequences
for innocent people cops and even the
suspects themselves the National
Institute of Justice's restrictive
policies for high-speed police Pursuits
document admits that vehicle Pursuits
are possibly the most dangerous of all
ordinary police activities and that far
more police vehicle chases occur each
year than police shootings in 2015 the
International Association of chiefs of
police presented a model policy that
started with a basic suggestion only
start a vehicle Pursuit if the fleeing
suspect presents a danger to human life
and skip Pursuits for minor violations
and the iacp also detailed a range of
factors from Road configuration to
lighting and visibility that officers
should consider to determine whether a
Chase would result in a greater Hazard
to the community than finding other ways
to NAB the bad guy if it really is a GTA
scene with a souped-up Camaro and a dude
with a machine gun in the passenger seat
then yeah you should probably rein them
in but that's an exception so rare that
Rockstar needed a thousand people and
years to develop a simulated version of
it the blame really begins when the cop
cars lights Flash and a driver chooses
to slam on the gas to escape
consequences the police are generally
just doing their job but until humans
miraculously abide by all laws willingly
comply with law enforcement and don't
freak out and make really terrible
decisions it's simply on the police to
not make a bad situation a lot worse
some police departments have quietly
restricted police chases but with a
nationwide increase in traffic crimes
the pendulum is swinging back to the
chase an ace a mind blow worthy Tech is
being employed too and it really needs
to work because we're destroying lives
75 year old Dorothy Wright and her two
grandchildren were killed when an
unarmed car thief crashed into them as
he was chased by cops just south of
Atlanta the suspect literally walked
away without being arrested and the
police didn't catch him for another six
years Dorothy and her grandchildren were
just on their way to church
we are culturally politically and often
personally obsessed with complex
societal problems that are a tangled web
of trade-offs incentives hidden costs
and intractable human behavior the
harder it is to solve the more we seem
to be consumed by it yet here's an
obvious problem with an extremely simple
solution that benefits everyone
and no one cares
what does that say about us
and as always thanks for watching
[Music]
foreign